we begin with this America talking about
you millions of Americans are waking up
with fewer restrictions this morning on
their daily lives federal guidelines to
slow the spread of the coronavirus
expired at midnight so now at least 33
states have now eased their own rules
while some other states extend orders to
stay home and reported infections
continue to rise
Tony the state's extending restrictions
include Michigan which has the third
most deaths in the country hundreds of
people protested at the state's capital
in Lansing yesterday including some with
guns demanding the governor and her stay
at home policy and across the country in
California large crowds on beaches in
Orange County California last weekend
led the state's governor to order them
closed starting today let's get the
Carter Evans in Huntington Beach
California Carter good morning how does
that decision being received not so well
there's a lot of frustration here in
Huntington Beach people feel the
governor is overreaching well the
governor says it's really just a matter
of public health it's the same back and
forth push and pull across the country
as different states take different paths
towards reopening the images we saw a
few of our beaches we're disturbing
California Governor Gavin Newsom is
cracking down closing Orange County
beaches over concerns that crowds last
weekend were jeopardizing public health
when you pull back too quickly you
literally put people's lives at risk
but his order frustrated some Orange
County residents and some local
officials were you surprised at the
governor's announcement I was a little
surprised and quite disappointed he's
singling out Orange County it's uncalled
for in Michigan the Democratic governor
extended the state's coronavirus
emergency declaration by executive order
Thursday night after the
republican-controlled legislature
declined to do so the worst thing we
could do is to abandon all social
distancing to pretend like we are done
with Cove in 19 and resume
life as it was this after defiant
protesters again demonstrated to the
state's capital to mandate an end to the
statewide stay at home order at least
six states recently extended their
lockdown orders into May but even more
states have just relaxed their social
distancing guidelines that means
businesses in some states are reopening
with limits potentially providing
economic relief to some of the thirty
million plus Americans that filed for
unemployment in the last six weeks in
Texas restaurants can begin dining
services today operating at twenty five
percent capacity we just got to make
sure the most is working the most at the
moment
Chuck Ganim owns two house of pies
restaurants in the Houston area and
employs 130 people he says while they're
ecstatic to come back they're also being
flexible you know but we just have to
take as many precautions to make sure
that everybody stays healthy as much as
possible now there will be a rally right
here in Huntington Beach today one of
several around the country really to
protest lockdown conditions and in at
least half a dozen states workers for
companies like instacart Amazon and
FedEx will be protesting working
conditions during the pandemic Anthony
Carter thank you